you're perfect for onna which is why we
can't wait to see you pop the question
in frozen - we've been rooting for you
ever since the very beginning Christophe
and you totally pulled through you and
onna are two birds of a feather and
you're going to make wonderful parents
someday but tell us Christophe how are
you going to ask for Ana's hand in
marriage
we're dying to know all the details but
don't worry she's definitely going to
say yes Princess Anna of arendelle and
Kristoff have been going strong ever
since they fell in love and frozen but
now it's time for Kristoff to lock
things down watch until the end to find
out how Kristoff will ask Anna to marry
him in frozen - so so now what fans are
super excited to watch frozen to the
hype is real and Disney isn't about to
let their fans down frozen - we'll hit
the big screen on November 20th 2019 and
it's sure to be the biggest Disney movie
of the year
after all it's trailer has already
amassed over 60 million views on YouTube
alone but just when we thought that
frozen - couldn't get any more exciting
we find out that Kristoff is going to
propose to Anna come the sequel the
proposing to the princess of arendelle
is no small feat which is why Kristoff
is probably sweating bullets on August
24th 2019 Disney spilled some very
exciting news during their annual d23
convention they dropped a sneak peak
that only a few lucky people were able
to see with their very own eyes but
luckily they were allowed to talk about
what happened during the private
screening it's been confirmed that
Kristoff will attempt to propose to Anna
at the very beginning of the film but
unfortunately Anna won't notice him get
down on one knee so why will the
princess of arendelle miss her
boyfriend's grand gesture well you
guessed it she's going to be too
preoccupied with her big sister Elsa
who's in for the ride of her life come
frozen - at the very beginning of the
sequel we'll see Anna Elsa Kristoff and
Olaf playing a game of charades Elsa
will be totally distracted which will
catch on its attention
soon after Elsa will hear a strange
sound and leave the room once the room
is cleared Kristoff will get down on
me and it's time to propose Donna but
she'll dismiss herself without ever
looking back so while Anna leaves to
find out what's wrong with Elsa
Christoph's proposal will fall flat but
don't worry guys he's bound to get it
right the second time around being left
on one knee with a ring in his hands
will definitely make Kristof's cheeks go
red but in the end it's a good thing
that Anna didn't catch Kristoff in the
act since it's probably a good idea for
Kristoff to talk to Elsa first she is
the queen of arendelle after all and
since Ana's parents are no longer in the
picture it would be nice for on it to
know that Elsa is on board when she says
yes after all this isn't honest first
time at the rodeo she met fell for and
agreed to marry Hans in the first frozen
film which didn't sit right with Elsa
you asked for my blessing but my answer
is no when Elsa found out that her
little sister was going to marry a
stranger she all but lost it and out of
her coronation no less Kristoff should
totally ask for Elsa's blessing ahead of
time but Christoph's proposal isn't the
only thing that will happen in frozen to
the movie does center around an epic
quest above all else and Elsa will
finally find out where her powers come
from Elsa Anna Kristoff Sven and Olaf
will journey into the unknown and things
are bound to get dangerous
christop will probably keep trying to
propose to honour throughout the quest
only to realize that now's not a good
time
but before we reveal how Kristoff will
propose to Anna let's double back and
find out where Kristoff gets on his
engagement ring from since arendelle's
best ice Harvester was raised by trolls
we're guessing that boldo will be the
one to give Kristoff a very special
crystal the trolls will probably help
Kristoff make Ana's engagement ring and
surely they'll want to give onna the
most beautiful crystal in all of the
valley on his ring will probably stay
hidden in Kristoff coat pocket for most
of the sequel but we're guessing that
he'll show it off by the end of the film
1 Sanne is safe and sound in arendelle
Kristoff will get down on
me and finally asked her to marry him
she's going to be so surprised since
it's a royal engagement the entire
kingdom of arendelle will be there to
see their princess get engaged Kristoff
is more of a lone wolf but we reckon
that he's going to be tired of waiting
for the perfect moment to ask for ahna
for her hand in marriage so we think
he's going to pop the question as soon
as they enter the arendelle gates the
whole town will go quiet causing ahna to
finally turn around and see Kristoff
down on one knee on a might joke around
at first but she's definitely going to
say yes there probably won't be enough
time to see Kristoff and onna get
married and frozen to but Disney is
known for coming out with the short
films whoa gross so we're bound to see
Kristoff and onna get married sooner
than later how do you think Kristoff is
going to propose to on and frozen to
tell us in the comments give this video
a big thumbs up if you can't wait to see
Chris top and onna get married and
subscribe to the things for more fun
content
thank you for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]